welcome everyone to the closing ceremony
of this year's sinful cup and 2022 grand
chess tour
hello hans
it's a pleasure to be here with everyone
and i get to thank everybody that makes
this event happen first of all thank you
to shannon bailey and everybody at the
world chess hall of fame that puts
together not only this closing ceremony
but this beautiful exhibit that you can
see throughout the museum of of course
bobby fischer against boris basking
thank you of course genie and
rexingfield for their vision and for
everything that they do for american
chess no one of us will be here without
it
[Applause]
of course a big thank you to the
masterminds behind the grand chess tour
gary kasparov and michael korkowski
[Applause]
and of course they handle everything at
the chess club joy bray and tony rich
i would like to thank our european
sponsors of the gct super bet and of
course the sponsors here uh the saint
louis chess club in america
and i well
i get to introduce the executive
director of the st louis chess club to
say some words tony rich
[Applause]
thank you alejandro you know when my
husband retired and and moved back to st
louis he said he wanted oh wait i'm
sorry genie i've got your notes let me
let me go back to working on my notes
here
really thank you all for joining us
tonight the grand chess tour was indeed
gary kasparov's um
uh baby his idea um and now that we've
held our
uh what is this the sixth year of the
grand chess tour uh it's amazing to look
back
sorry seventh year this coveted year i
mean it really screws everything up
right right right no of course um you
know i look back to that first year of
the grand chess tour and it was just
four players well sorry to the first
year of the syncfield cup we just had
four players and then the first year of
the grand chess tour we just had three
events and since then the grand chess
tour has really grown and matured and
become a circuit of tournaments that
really is second to none the grand chess
tour represents what professional chess
should be from an organizer's
perspective hopefully from the sponsor's
perspective and i know certainly from
the fans perspective it's been an
amazing uh series of events to watch and
i can't wait to see next year's grand
chess tour without further ado it's my
pleasure to introduce to you the
executive director of the grand chess
tour michael korkowski
[Applause]
thank you tony
a
small correction it was
already seven events and we're at the
conclusion of the seventh season
of the grand chess tour
it would be eighth if not covet and we
are very proud that the grand chess tour
evolves
and has
many many advantages right now
especially that we have
a second very strong
uh sponsor super bad foundation
and actually i would like
i wanted to to keep you at suspense but
i want to tell you that
uh super bad foundation already
confirmed three events for next year we
are working on those details
uh with them but
for three winners here who already
secured their spots outright
uh for next year please save the date
it's bucharest
and warsaw from may 20 to 26.
more details to come and zagreb july 3rd
to 10th
uh saint louis rapid and blessings in
field cup
to be
determined a little bit later
and
i would like
also to
congratulate winners
uh
i just asked
rex before
uh before
closing ceremony
when it was last time when two french
nationals came here grab so much money
and will go away without it
so he actually said it was probably
during the civil war
american realm
so next year we are going to have five
events
and hopefully top two winners will
qualify
uh to play further at the candidates
tournament
and
last but not least i would like to thank
my entire staff starting with joy bray
general manager
of saint louis chess club technical
director tony ridge
uh today is absent tony pribanova from
czech republic
uh who actually always taking care of
these kids
as younger brothers
uh entire
group of
our unparalleled strong commentators yes
sir ceremony
christian chirila
[Applause]
alejandra ramirez
peter swiddler
and one and only
anastasia cartilage
and of course it will not be happening
if we would not have such a great group
of broadcast
specialists
from silverback
and
and spectrum
especially
kevin duggan kevin d pew
marcus and brian so thank you very much
all of you without you this will not be
happening and of course sponsors super
bad foundation and
sinful
rex and dr
ginny singhfield and i would like
to invite
dr jeannie sinfield
[Applause]
well this has been an interesting
tournament
so let's go back a little bit and think
about the history of the sink field cup
right
2013 this is our ninth year
prior prior to
prior to this year okay we had eight
tournaments and we had six different
winners
from six different countries
so here we go
larry is coming to america he's never
been here before and he's going to play
against
four individuals in the tournament who
already won at least once if not twice
the tournament
and guess what
we now have a second winner
and i want to explain to you why we have
so many different winners
st louis has the best water anywhere in
the world
so anyway anyway my real job here is to
introduce rex
so you're wait you're waiting aren't you
okay i'm going to be nice
the godfather of american chess rex
singfield
[Applause]
well thank you all what an amazing
tournament
despite that little interlude it was
really a great one
and uh as we wrap up the 2022 season and
say goodbye to all the players we look
forward to next year i especially want
to thank gary kasparov for his vision
support and direction of the grand chess
tour
and as i mentioned at the opening
ceremony please be sure to visit the
fisher spassky exhibit if you haven't
had a chance
you are really missing out on amazing
work that the staff of the world chess
hall of fame put together
it's hard to believe that it was 50
years
some of us lived and breathed that event
every day
it was remarkable i hope we see one like
that again
so it's been incredible having all of
you here in st louis and i congratulate
you for your performance and ali raza i
have to tell you that the st louis board
of aldermen
passed an ordinance today which is the
governing body of st louis and it says
that you are not permitted to leave
so
thank you all ladies and gentlemen thank
you players very much
[Applause]
and now the mastermind behind the grand
chess tour gary kasparov
[Applause]
thank you rex thank you ginny so for all
of us being here um
it's a becomes a tradition now every
year you know it's in louise you know
time and again
and i was thinking this morning so when
i just the play landed in in
so
how did we meet you know sometimes you
know the big mistake actually could be
so the
prelude to something really nice
so it was the
it was a really ill-conceived uh carpool
feeder presidential campaign
yeah but you know as a result of this
campaign i met rex
so who already had his vision about
turning saint louis into something
magnificent yeah but he had very small
ambitions to make it a capital of the
united states yes so i thought we could
we have to think about something much
bigger to turn into the chess capital of
the world and and we did
yeah and um and we get few few ideas so
how we can move things forward and as
you know i spent a
long time so just as many players
actually were not born when i started my
campaign against feed the unprofessional
treatment of the game of chess
and it was very unsuccessful i have to
say before i met rex and now we have a
tournament uh that is part actually was
the it was the beginning of this network
that have been created grandchild's tour
which is and undoubtedly the most
important and you know most likely will
be the only professional network of the
chess tournaments uh uh um in the world
and now with super bet with the with the
second wing of this operation now
european on the european side so we can
look into the future with great
confidence
uh it's um it's it's all secured and uh
and again it will grow as as tony said
you know it took you step by steps and
when you had the first event here in
2015 it was relatively small so and now
it's uh it's massive and i could see
only us growing bigger uh bigger and
bigger uh but uh also i thought that's
um you know
it's an amazing moment now because uh
it is this year we saw something that
i used to be a long long long time ago i
was to be the youngest player in the
tournaments you know and even just the
youngest world champion now it always
makes me just a great gives me a great
pleasure to talk about generational
change
and we already saw
the this uh it's uh some
earth-shattering event in india at the
chess olympiad with a very young team
from
many people know where the country is
uzbekistan won the event and and then
the india two teams so did performed
extremely well and uh here we saw you
know just it's the
that's it's it's not just accident it's
a trend
so um ali reza could repeat you know
following
uh
julius caesar you know veni vidsu so i
came i saw and i won so obviously you
know wesley made a great contribution to
this great accomplishment
so no offense meant basically
yeah but in any case so this tournament
again made history we have a a new
winner winner of the tournament sinful
cup and the winner of granchester a
teenager so again that means we can look
in the future with great confidence but
you know with all these changes you know
rex it's always nice you know because
the world is now it's a very
um
unsteady place
yeah but we all know that whatever
happens
next year we'll meet in saint louis and
we'll you know this this tournament you
know will become will become even more
and more prestigious because it will be
the crown jewel of something that will
build together thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you gary uh i'd like to thank a
couple of people that haven't been
mentioned yet our journalist
international master jose kavutsky and
the production assistant
[Applause]
uh varu nakobian
[Applause]
i
usually say that if we don't hear from
them at all they're doing a great job
but we heard from them a little bit our
arbiters chris bird and enrique huerta
[Applause]
and finally to announce the prize
winners we actually had a special prize
of four this year sing field cup we have
a brilliancy price courtesy of brian
priester it goes for five thousand
dollars
uh
it was
done by us the commentators we chose the
game
and it was head and shoulders above the
rest
it's five thousand more dollars for
somebody that already won a lot of money
alareza farouja for his win against
levon neronian
now for the results of the sink field
cup
tied for third place we have two
americans fabiano caruana and wesley saw
[Laughter]
[Applause]
second place of the sinkhole cup
jane pogbachie
[Applause]
and now i have a whole list of things
that this guy won i mean let's start the
winner of the 2022 singfield cup with
five out of eight points and winning the
playoff grand master already
[Applause]
he said about two weeks ago when he came
here for the opening ceremony of the
saint louis rapid and blitz that he had
a dream to play in the st louis chess
club well he played and he won plenty
also the winner of the grand chess tour
with 36 and a half tour points is grand
master alireza ferrugia
he wins a cool combined total at the
grand chess tour this year of 277
thousand dollars
[Applause]
and now i would like to invite rex genie
and tony for some pictures and award
giving
i think somebody's supposed to
you know you don't get to talk anymore
this is our talk
you want to bring it out come on bring
it up
hey you know what i'd like to have the
prior winners that are here
mlb and come close right
you're a prior winner right
and uh wesley come on
come on these are the prior winners
right
come on wesley and everyone else stand
up we love you too come on
so
think about this this is who you were
who was supposed to win right
okay
so here we go
2022 sink field cup winner
congratulations sean
[Applause]
yeah speech speech
okay come on wait you wanna you don't
have any speeches here why you didn't
win
yeah i'm really happy to be here again
and it's a really great honor for me to
play in
the saint louis chess club um as i said
before it's a dream come true for me
really because when i started playing
chess everything also started here i
think around 2013 and 2012 so when i was
growing up i was looking at the games
until 4 00 a.m 5 p.m here and all these
guys were fighting and
i really learned a lot so the fact that
i am i am now playing even here is a
really great honor for me
and
yeah obviously it's i never thought i
could win one of these tournaments very
soon but okay i'm happy that it happened
very fast and
and
and i want to really thank dr ginny and
rex and gary also for making all this
effort to
make the chess tournaments happen i know
it's very difficult task to do
these days and
i'm really i really appreciate
everything they do for the game of chess
and yeah i want to say thank you to
everybody
[Applause]
thank you reza and for me it was a great
honor to be at the eye of this great
hurricane over the last couple of weeks
thank you for the audience that watches
our games i know that everybody fights
for the audience and with that we come
to our conclusion of the 2022 singfield
cup and grand chess tour thank you and
good night
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you